hi Jennifer how are you you have to turn
your radio down like Kelly told you to
Jennifer yes I'm sorry
that's okay how can I help I have
stumbled across the show this past
Friday and it was a couple on there
saying that I had a zero credit score
and they was happy about it and you was
happy for them and I I was just
intrigued and then I turned on the show
again today after I had called my mother
and she was like zero credit for what do
you mean it's impossible but I'm about
maybe 40 $50,000 in bed I'm a single
parent and I just I wanted the help and
I was intrigued by what was being talked
about okay well a zero the credit score
itself is put out by an organization
called FICO and you call a FICO score
you've probably heard that and and FICO
has developed a mathematical process for
determining how worthy someone is to
borrow money the mathematical process is
100% based on you having borrowed money
recently okay and so when you pay
payments it develops your FICO score or
your credit score when you have zero
accounts with debt of any kind open or
with a balance of any kind no balances
and no open accounts at all within about
six months to a year your credit score
will disappear because you have no
active accounts of any kind for instance
I've not borrowed money in 25 years and
I have an auto credit score in 20 years
okay and that's that's how you get there
but you'd have to pay off the fifty
thousand dollars we're talking about
what you need to do and we'll help you
do that and get out of debt and don't
have any payments of any kind and that's
the reason for heading there the the
reason we were happy about a zero credit
score is it means you're not paying
payments and you're not paying interest
and that's wonderful because then that
gives you all of your income to build
wealth with and to be generous with so
so what do you make a year right now I'm
at sixty thousand I just left a
corporate career and I've run into real
estate so I decide with my company and
I'm
now a new real estate agent okay and so
you left the job making 60,000 yes and
you've gone straight Commission
full-time yes okay have you been selling
houses I just recently started when I
left the job they it was a payout and so
I've actually been living off of the
money from the payout for the past
couple of months while I was in school
and doing those type of things okay all
right I know it I feel like some of the
times I haven't made the best decision
well you're gonna get with it that's for
sure you got to get out there and sell a
bunch of houses so you can make sixty
thousand right right have you calculated
what how many what that is
I mean if I average out of doing the
printing of that I'm selling the rental
houses plus the actual selling of the
new buyers and this and that if I sell
to make a commission of at least two
thousand to six thousand dollars a house
and if I sell at least three houses a
month which is you know astronomical
goal but I can you know strive for it
and I'm hopefully you know within the
2/3 a year you're gonna have to hit that
or you're gonna take a pay cut doing
this right right okay so get with it you
can do it but basically at six percent
commission that would be a million
dollars worth of transactions you're
part of the transaction not counting
your split with your broker and not
counting other stuff and I kind your
expenses out-of-pocket and so on and so
you're gonna have to do million and a
half and volume to break-even with your
old job not counting the rental stuff
and the rental stuff obviously pays
differently so you can calculate that
out and work it out and get it done what
kind of debt is the fifty thousand I
mean I even serious is fifty thousand
like I said I just listened to your show
so I'm not the best when it comes to
actually looking I have maybe a few
student loans and at the particular time
the student loans were coming out of my
check when I was working and so right
now they're not getting paid right but
they I got those down I thought and then
so remember I was just listening to you
you said that the credit people can call
and call so I really thought I was
actually finished with a student loan
and but then all of a sudden you know
the calls came so
my fault for not being as due diligent
as I should yeah you know so you got to
get on the student loans and figure out
what those balances are how much do you
owe on your car knuckle I say four good
what other debts do you have
I ran the house and says volume right
now and I'm all wrong credit car much
wrong credit cards do you have right now
it was fine until you know actually you
know left the job so right now I'm at
ten thousand and credit card okay so
you're gonna stop that you have to get
some money coming in and live on what
you make because the first step to
getting out of debt is stop borrowing
more right okay so if you got ten
thousand there plus your student loans
and you don't have a car payment then
we've just got to figure out what that
is and then you'll know what your goal
is to get started in this stuff paid off
and like you said being really diligent
is a big part of it it's a big part of
the deal
so can absolutely be done now we have a
nine week class called Financial Peace
University you go one night a week for
nine weeks to learn how to handle money
get on a budget get out of debt and
become wealthy if you'd like to go to
that I'll give it to you as my gift all
right you hold on and I'll have Kelly
pick up and we'll get you signed up and
then you report back to me later and
tell me how you're doing as you go
through that class I want to see you
when it's time for you to get control
and once you go saw a bunch of real
estate
- hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]